tonight is is no ordinary night as
everybody here knows and anybody
watching those in about 35 minutes
probably 34 minutes now thanks to your
whoo in about 34 minutes David Letterman
is going to air his last episode of
late-night
it's a huge deal everybody this past
week has been struggling to explain what
this man has meant what his leaving
television means to us personally but
let's face it there simply are no words
that can encapsulate the sheer magnitude
of what dave has achieved these past 33
years it can't be done it cannot be done
he is he's been the North Star for me
and for every comic of my generation I
tried to explain in an essay for
Entertainment Weekly came out about a
week or so ago
just how much David Letterman changed
the face of comedy for me if that's of
interest to you and you're okay with
actually reading something go online and
check it out it's free would I when I
said free people like oh then I'll try
it
what I wanted to talk about tonight
briefly is something incredible that
that Dave did for me almost 22 years ago
something that had a profound impact on
my life some of you may be too young to
know this but way back in 1993 I took
over David Letterman's iconic late-night
television show I was a complete unknown
with absolutely no experience performing
on television I was utterly and totally
unprepared for that enormous job I don't
think anything like that could happen
today I don't think the government would
allow it you know we can check people
out on YouTube now right but then I was
a complete unknown I wasn't prepared and
after going on the air in September of
1993 I got the kicked out of me
okay
critics despised me the readings were
bad my skin broke out
it hadn't done that since high school
and then again at this crucial time that
is true and my network started to make
it clear that I probably wouldn't be
around very long no no I honestly I
honestly I honestly have no ill will
about that time because by and large
people were right I'm serious I was in
way over my head
and what I love you too yeah I was no
seriously that's not why I'm saying any
of this okay I'm telling you I was in
way over my head and with this hair
that's saying something and the
conventional wisdom everybody thought
that I should be immediately canceled
and then something miraculous happened
after for really dreary months out of
the blue we got a message at the show
that David Letterman wanted to come on
the program as a guest now understand
Dave wasn't just the biggest late-night
star at the time he was the biggest
thing on television he didn't go on
other people's shows it was like The
Beatles asking Maury Povich if they
could stop by and sing a couple of tunes
it was that absurd and at the time I was
convinced it was a prank I didn't think
this could be real but on February 28th
1994 David Letterman walked onto my set
and he blew the doors off the place it's
easily one of the happiest nights of my
professional life I'd like to take just
a second go back and take a peek and I
first got this job I came here to 30
rock did you get this job team writing
contest yes
yes so what would I do with the talk
show and I was fourth
I look like a melting Girl Scout
anyway absolutely true story after that
night that one night that one appearance
everything turned around for me the
morale of the staff shot to the ceiling
my producer my writers Andy we all
thought that if David Letterman can come
on our show and say a few kind words
maybe just maybe we can earn the right
to be here
and we survive here's the point the
point behind all of this is that I just
want you to know tonight that if you
have ever liked any silly or stupid
thing that I've done on television over
the 22 years you must know you must know
that it probably never never would have
happened if it weren't for Dave at one
of the at one of the lowest points of my
life when I was a 30 year old national
punchline Dave for reasons I still don't
really understand completely rescued me
I truly believe that simple act of
kindness turned everything around and
made all the difference so ladies and
gentlemen here's the plan for tonight I
have no illusions anyone is watching me
this evening okay but if there happened
to be a few of you out there probably
stoners I'm gonna let you know I know my
crowd I'm gonna let you know I'm gonna
let you know the exact moment when
Dave's show is starting and I'd like you
to switch over I may be talking to seven
viewers at that time but I'd really
think you should do it and here's why
and trust me I want you to record this
show and watch it in a few days and just
focus on the commercials you can
fast-forward but that's
come on watch the commercials free time
but please switch over and watch Dave
and I'll tell you why I promise you we
will not see a man of his talents and
comedic integrity again in our lifetime
you cannot miss out have a great show
day the great show I'm acting as if he's
watching he's not watching maybe they'll
show it to him have a great show Dave
and from the bottom of my heart thank
you so much we'll be right back